we know it will allow us to live longer
it will give us more energy it will
boost our willpower
they said the blueprints of life you
know all diseases are created from genes
turns out less than 5% more like 1% of
people on the planet are born with a
genetic condition like type 1 diabetes
or tay-sachs disease it's really
important for us to take on a learning
role and say I am creating this
situation and I can uncreate this
situation without the use of drugs wanna
be happy build a life not just a
business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you two
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the five
habits that will actually improve your
health
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one exploit the power of exercise with
Robin Sharma right now you're probably
an entrepreneur or maybe a business
builder a creative person of some sort
or you're building a family or you're
building an empire of spirituality or
you're working on your health whatever
it is you have some mountaintop that
you're chasing and along the way it is a
little bit of a war it could be a war of
self-doubt it could be a war against
temptation it could be a war against
distraction because we all have these
competing diversions looking for our
attention versus staying manö maniacally
focused on the few projects or pursuits
that'll get us to where we want to get
to so I'm going to get right into it the
first part of the deconstruction about
how warriors battle proof elite health
is exercise we know the power of
movement and yet so few of us exploit
the power of exercising every day we
know that if we exercise we know it will
allow us to live longer it will give us
more energy it will boost our willpower
it'll release dopamine the inspirational
neurotransmitter so we feel stronger
it'll release serotonin so we feel more
relaxed
we know exercise promotes neurogenesis
so you'll have more brain cells we know
it actually accelerates learning and
processing we know it releases BDNF
brain-derived neurotrophic factor that
John Ratey calls Miracle Grow for the
brain
in his wonderful book spark so why
wouldn't you exercise every single day
and we not many people love getting up
at 5:00 in the morning and exercising
for at least 20 minutes but think about
how you feel after those 20 minutes you
feel phenomenal and it's your neuro
chemistry at work and your neurobiology
at work and you have this in you it's
the way your brain and body has been
constructed you just gotta force
yourself to wire it into a habit and if
you believe me and there's tons of
science that proves it but if you
believe me that exercises a total
GameChanger and I recommend to you do it
first thing in the morning because the
rest of your day in terms of your
mindset heart set health set and soul
set productivity and performance and
Happiness is fundamentally different why
would you only do it once a day so my
encouragement with great love and
respect is do it from 5:00 to 5:20 and
then at the end of your workday do a
second wind workout this is one of the
rituals that I teach up my live events
like personal mastery Academy where I
walk you through all my advanced
protocols on exponential performance
battle proofing your mindset building a
great company living a world-class life
and one of the rituals that I teach at
personal mastery Academy is this
protocol it's called the second wind
work out the second wind workout and so
if you believe that exercise increases
your energy and your focus and your
happiness and your productivity why
would you only do it once a day so at
the end of your work day you do a second
wind workout it could be a yoga class it
could be a soul cycle class it could be
walking in nature as I love to do on
most days or going for a mountain bike
ride because when you exercise in nature
it's amazing what starts to happen you
get the fresh air you get the sunlight
you get the color of the leaves or you
reconnect to your spiritual self you get
to breathe the fresh air amazing so the
first point is really warriors
understand the power of exercise to
strengthen their interior core and their
energy reserves and their mindsets of
the win in battle well number two
meditate with Joe Dispenza many years
ago after the DNA helix was discovered
by Watson and Crick
they said the blueprints of life you
know all diseases are created from genes
it turns out less than 5% more like 1%
of people on the planet are born with a
genetic condition like type 1 diabetes
or tay-sachs disease or sickle cell
anemia the other 95 to 99 percent are
created by lifestyle and by choices you
can take two identical twins exact same
genome one dies at 51 the other one dies
at 85 hmm same gene different
environment so all of a sudden they said
we lied that was wrong it's not genes
that create disease it's the environment
that signals the gene that creates
disease well ok but that's not the whole
truth - because you could have two
people working side by side in the same
factory one gets cancer after being
exposed to a carcinogenic for 25 years
both working for 25 years the other one
has no cancer at all so there must be
some internal order that would cause one
person to not get it while another one
does so is it possible then if the
environment signals the gene and it does
and the end product of an experience in
the environment is called an emotion can
you signal the gene ahead of the
environment by embracing an elevated
emotion we've done the research on this
where we've measured 7,500 different
gene expressions in a group of people it
came to an advanced event for four days
and we had them doing a seated
meditation a walking meditation a laying
down meditation a standing meditation
and at the end of four days just four
days the common eight genes that were
upregulated two genes to suppress cancer
cells and tumor growth two genes for
neurogenesis the growth of new neurons
in response to novel experiences and
learning the gene that signals stem
cells to go to damaged areas and repair
them the gene for oxidative stress was
upregulated we started seeing all these
genes that are very
healthy to cause the body to flourish
imagine if people were doing that for
three months we also measured telomeres
the little shoestrings on the end of DNA
that tell us our biological age we asked
people to do the work
meditation five out of seven days for 60
days measure their telomeres that
determine their biological age sixty
days later seventy four percent of the
people lengthen their telomeres 40
percent significant change twenty
percent a very remarkable change that
means that they got a little bit of
their life back if it lengthened by ten
percent they got 10% of their life back
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence and self-love
check out my 254 series they're free the
links to join are in the description
below to become fearless why not find
some time every day to practice becoming
fearless stop resisting I encourage you
stop resisting the natural flow of epic
performance stop resisting the natural
seasons of life you're up and dressed
and ready to go before your parents are
up you know why cuz you knew something
unexpected was gonna happen that's how
we should live our lives waking up with
the understanding to expect the
unexpected rule number three work on
your belief system with Bruce Lipton in
this world it is true that people want
immediate action that's the world we
live in immediate gratification so if
I'm sick I want something immediately to
handle the issue and of course we look
to the world of drugs for for this
understanding but the problem with this
is there are more effective ways of
healing now the problem with the energy
healing is that it really involves
consciousness mine and our ability to
change our belief systems well this
takes a little bit more work than
popping a pill and in fact I just here
at my own particular case I remember
years ago when I was getting off on this
out of my conventional medical academic
background and coming into this world
and I faced a stressful situation where
I got pneumonia and I started to realize
at some point it's okay I'm gonna sit
here and and grab a hold of this with my
conscious
my spirit and get my immune system all
pumped up and work on this and I started
to realize that the the bacteria were
dividing faster than my ability to
control the bacteria and so it came at a
realistic moment it said yes I know I
can possibly control this but the effort
that it's going to take is going to take
a little bit more time than the drug so
I actually went and bought the
penicillin and the significance is when
you need it you need it at that moment
but the issue is had I not been stressed
had I taken care of my health a little
bit better I would not have come to that
precipice where I was forced into taking
the drugs and so the reality is that in
switching from a drug based reality into
an energy medicine spirit based reality
we have to go through a learning curve
and learn how to take control of our
thoughts our mind and control the
biology that we were given when we do
that then it's far better than the drug
world for a very simple reason there are
no side effects and so basically it says
that if you start healing with spirit
and energy that you get an unencumbered
healing process as compared to dealing
with drugs and then dealing with the
myriad side effects that are listed on
all the packages so it says both work
but one is far superior to the other and
yet I wouldn't throw out the medication
because when it's necessary it's
necessary but it's just a little warning
to you when your symptoms start going up
it says pay attention to the symptoms
because the symptoms are really
informing you that you're not living in
harmony or in health and that the body
is telling you this and so rather than
shutting off the symptoms with a drugged
it's really important for us to take on
a learning role and say I am creating
this situation and I can uncreate the
situation without the use of drugs rule
number four improve your sleep patterns
with Pedro school Ian I've had the best
coach over the last seven years that
I've known him and that's Craig
Valentine what do you thinks the biggest
lesson you learned from him in the last
seven eight years the biggest lesson was
to sleep at the same time wake up at the
same time seven days a week no matter
what really his sleep is so valuable
it's so important so I rated I
to think that I here's what I was I'm a
fighter jet I would literally walk
around the house honey I'm a fighter jet
fighter jet and you know doesn't even
come down to get refueled they're up
there getting revealed right we've all
seen the YouTube videos
yeah well the fighter jet if they leave
those afterburners on too long they just
fall out of the sky which I know one had
told me right until I fell out of the
sky I was having essential tremors and
anxiety attacks and not realizing it and
as I got better it's sleep those just
went away cuz the one discipline leads
to another and to another how you do
anything is how you know everything
alright and so that that one thing that
he taught me or I learned through him
and we'd be in Vegas we'd run a
mastermind together because now we run a
mastermind together and eight o'clock
he's gone buddy were you going sleep
yeah I'm gonna buy nine or whatever
better yeah yeah exactly he powers off
thirty minutes all his electronics
before so now I do the same thing I
power off I don't go to bed and then do
this yeah
I powered off thirty minutes before and
my mind stops racing and the left and
right side start reconciling of the
information I took in throughout the day
versus the information I keep consuming
taking yeah right until I fall asleep
and then Lord knows what happens in my
brain whatever I write what time you go
to bed and wake up 10:30 10:30 I'm in
bed wake up at 5:30 Wow and and that's
it's about no matter what even if you're
in Vegas or I'm traveling around the
world or whatever you know I'll adjust
to that timezone real quickly and 10:30
I'm in bed 5:30 a.m. I wake up and I go
right through my rituals and rule number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is used a wim HOF method with
wim HOF I created a method the
components are breathing
mindset and cold exposure gradual
non-forest cold exposure and that's to
optimize the mind-body connection women
has figured out ways namely through
breath work and through exposure to cold
to take conscious control over aspects
of his physiology that for most people
they simply can't tune into in control
[Music]
the cold my warm friend it brings about
a whole lot of more energy and that were
together with breathing makes you so
powerful but then you lose your wife and
a dull rumbles down for children at
birth for my wife and there was to be
with her forever she was the love of my
life she died she suicided it's a it's a
black hole within yourself it breaks
your heart and you don't know why but
the Train of a daily life is going on
and you gotta catch up otherwise you
lose it
so I had to be there for my children and
yes we created a new nest but my
children made me survive in that time
but nature yield my words
the cold gave me a direct understanding
of deeper breathing and how to heal a
broken heart then I went did all kinds
of remarkable challenges apparently they
found it a very remarkable and great and
spectacular so came in contact with
television one after the other they
challenged me more more more more more
they go swim 50 meters are under the ice
go swim 100 meters under the earth climb
out everest ensures that lad up that the
scientists became curious hey what this
man is doing is not possible
physiologically
the science of what wim HOF method does
is one of the primary interests of my
lab now because it is so powerful and
spin shown to be powerful in the immune
system we believe it will also hold some
real potential for treatment of
neurologic diseases and this breathing
technique brings you right into the
deepest part of our physiology anybody
can do it so you become the alchemist of
your own chemistry they ask the
professors and all this scientific world
what's happening with this guy because
this is not possible they're genetically
the same imprint my brother and they see
he is not capable of doing what he is
capable of and why because I just drove
deeper it's by breeding if we just
breathe more deeply change the chemistry
inside not shallow breathing deep
breathing slowly but surely this is what
you do consciously can you do this 30
times the chemistry in the body in the
tissue is changing and it's changing so
that the body is becoming ox energized
alkaline and then suddenly the
brain-body connection is possible by
pressurizing by
[Music]
once you begin to have that connection
with the body then you are able to
connect within in the brain and that's
what we do right now with Stanford
University to get rid of PTSD fear
trauma and depression to learn to expand
consciousness and together with
breathing you create the right chemistry
and then the neurons they channel up and
thus your perception your consciousness
is gonna be you smell more you see their
colors brighter you experience deeper
and that's the brain and then connecting
once again with all the cells makes you
a beautiful living being there's a lot
of unnecessary suffering going on just
because people believe the wrong things
they believe in pills who believe in
medicines they believe depression cannot
be titled they believe you cannot enter
into your brain and I tell you we found
a way to get back to yourself they get
back to mother nature within us and make
some sense within yourself
you are the one who is able now to make
yourself happy strong and healthy and
that is entering in all those systems
just by by your mind your we we are
showing this through science but do you
need science when I already show this in
science with data scientific results
brain scans no speculation I tell you
but it takes time for publishing and and
to get it into books and to get it in
mainstream I tell you here and right now
if youtubes believe and and breathe and
take a cold shower for for God's sake
because it's good for your blood system
then you will become in their ability to
realign with the control within yourself
to become happy strong and healthy to
control your mood and your energy
management and all look at other wise up
because it is simple very effective it's
here right now so my message to yours
just breathe and believe now I've got a
really special bonus tip on how to
optimize your body with David Sinclair
but before that it's time for the
question of the day I want to know which
of these five habits do you need to
apply right now into your life let me
know put it down the comments below and
if you made it this far in a video
you're still here watching and you
promise you commit to yourself that
you're gonna take action we don't just
watch videos here believe nation we do
something about it
give me a hash tag believed on the
comments below up that's you so I can
celebrate with YouTube what should
people be doing to protect themselves -
you know maximize the strength of their
immunity to stay safe in this time other
obviously than physical distancing right
so the first thing I would say is if you
smoke stop immediately that's number one
hopefully all your viewers and listeners
don't smoke but that's that's the
biggest risk you can inflict on your
body in the in the Cobra nineteen era is
to be a smoker but you can actually
recover pretty quickly if you stop so
now would be the time for those of you
who cause of us who are not smokers you
still can optimize your body you want to
do some aerobics as it's called or
high-intensity interval training if
you're just in an apartment you can
still do one of they jumping jacks Tom
or what we call you star jumps that's
the minimum get your heart moving you
probably have noticed I'm actually
standing up for this interview I really
try to avoid sitting down because you
know I'm burning calories getting more
flexible my body is much better off than
sitting when I wrote my book for two
years I could barely walk after that my
muscles were so degraded in my hips so
that brings another point you want to be
doing flexibility and hip hinge
exercises in general especially as you
get older but specifically follow the
virus you don't want to be low in iron
so if you typically have some anemia
make sure you're not any because you
need your blog to be able to bring your
oxygen levels up I would focus my time
indeed now there's really good evidence
from studies and doctors advice that
vitamin D will
keep your immune system in tip-top shape
so I'm taking two and a half thousand
units a day of that shows my family I
eat I still eat less often than most
people I'm still skipping breakfast I
think a little bit of fasting during the
day can only have benefits for immune
system as long as you don't overdo it
and stop eating for a whole week I'm
also trying to keep my blood sugar
levels Lord you know not too low that
I'm passing out but what some Chinese
scientists have published is that the
virus can also attack red blood cells
where you have iron of course carries
oxygen and it's also thought that you
can damage your red blood cells the
hemoglobin by having too much sure and
in fact if you have a lot of blood so
that when you get a test for type 2
diabetes 2 what they're measuring is a
thing called hba1c and the H B stands
for hemoglobin and the it's basically
sugars attached to your hemoglobin which
have been speculated to make your blood
red blood cells more susceptible to the
virus
so in abundance of caution and if you
have type 2 diabetes it certainly can't
hurt you and will probably help you to
eat less often during the day I still
have really great dinners I eat normally
and I have a glass of red wine
typically with dinner so I'm not always
eating carrots so I'm with you you got
to live a little in life but now would
be the time to get into shape
if you want to know the morning routines
of the super-successful check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe I
don't see you that grand my never got up
early dad couldn't get up early I guess
I'm not the kind of person who could
rise before the Sun and what I would
suggest to you is simply this